Coffee on a Tuesday block 13.
Oh,
hey,
listen,
spider.
You're trying to scare me because it's
13 flood.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's right.
I said it.
Raising awareness is for pussies.
What we explained,
you can see very clearly on this diagram
that I just made,
that there are three different types of
rates.
You can raise awareness,
you can raise understanding,
or you can raise money.
Of those three,
clearly one stands out as being for
postings,
so all you fund hipsters out there who
grew your mustache for movember to raise
some awareness for prostate cancer.
I say yes,
it is better than doing nothing,
but you are nonetheless still pussies
to prove it to you.
I'm here at the Comerica Bank Tower in
downtown Los Angeles and I'm about to
walk up 50 flights of steps to raise
awareness for cystic fibrosis.
Look at all these pussies.
I'm going to do one better.
Not only am I going to climb 50 flights
of stairs when I'm going to raise some
understanding in the process,
so every 10 flights,
I'm going to explain a little bit more
to you about what?
Cystic.
Okay,
here we go.
Yeah,
you have a team that makes it
10 existing fibrosis is an inherited
disease that affects the lungs and the
digestive system and affected gene and
its protein product cause the body to
produce unusually thick and sticky
mucous that clogs the lungs that leads
to life threatening lung infections and
obstructs the pancreas which makes
enzymes that help the body break down
food and absorb nutrients.
Currently about 70,000
people in the world happened.
That's about 100,000,
so maybe you know someone who hasn't.
Maybe you don't.
I do these 22 years,
the median life expectancy of a sufferer
of cystic fibrosis days late 30,
50 years ago.
It was about six months necessarily 20,
already filled the muscle on the muscle,
burn up,
power it suffers of cystic fibrosis,
have a mutation on their seventh
chromosome on a gene called the cystic
fibrosis transmembrane conductance
regulator for cf ball,
cftr closest thick respiratory
secretions that are hard to clear from
the sewing bacteria become more easily
tracked and causing infection and
inflammation in the.
Also in the pancreas organ that helps
you break down all the fat,
protein,
carbs,
and fat.
You will find the disease blocks these
enzymes that prohibits digestion.
This means that necessarily fat soluble
score,
vitamins don't get absorbed into the
bloodstream.
Okay.
10 flights.
Honestly,
this is easy.
Thank you so much.
So the medicine,
we follow the same enzymes,
vitamins,
antibiotics to stop infection,
mucus thinner as an bronco.
Dilators to facilitate read,
suffers from cystic fibrosis,
digests less.
They have to eat more,
more calories and more fat all while
maintaining a healthy weight.
Because a healthy body makes for a
strong immune system.
And in this case it has to work
overtime.
Exercise like this is a must,
so let's
good.
Okay,
so how is their life different from
ours?
They have to take different medicines
all day long.
They have to use a nebulizer to inhale
special ms medicines directly into their
lungs.
They have to watch their sugar because
diabetes is especially prevalent among
the cystic fibrosis community.
They're in and out of the hospital.
They can't smoke cigarettes or marijuana
because they're especially susceptible
to fungal and bacteria.
They can drink alcohol,
but only in moderation though that might
be said for everyone should have
scratched,
shouldn't stress
like a before.
Thank you.
He's let it be known that Justin Syriana
the camera and also made it up 50
flights with me.
Thank you very much,
Jay.
That's not a trick.
Now.
That'd be really ready to take it away
at home.
Thanks Evan.
So do you remember the cft?
Rg?
Well,
here's what's happening on a molecular
level.
A gene is like a little instruction
manual.
It tells amino acids how to shape
themselves into proteins.
Proteins are these wildly complex shapes
like bunches of ribbon that perform
various functions in the bottle.
The shape is everything.
It's a name and a job all in one.
It tells everything around what it's
there to do.
The cftr protein coming from the CFTR
gene sits on the membrane of cells and
the coming and going of sodium chloride
or salt.
Okay,
good.
So far,
the mutation associated with cystic
fibrosis is a faulty instruction.
The protein is constructed wrong and
instead of facilitating the passions of
salt,
it blocks it.
And this is what creates the mucus
buildup and all the other troubles.
Now there's a drug in development by
vertex pharmaceuticals called VX seven,
seven.
It's a CFTR potentiator and it aims to
increase the function of those effective
cftr genes by increasing the gating
activity or the ability for ions to be
transported across the cell membrane.
It's currently in phase three of FDA
trials and it has had promising results
so far along partly due to the
fundraising done by the cystic fibrosis
foundation or the CFF.
And we can only hope for the best.
This is why raising understanding is
better than raising awareness because
you know where your money is going if
you donate to this cause,
you're donating to the research and
development of gene therapy treatments
that will attack this disease at its
root and potentially cure those affected
with cystic fibrosis forever.
We all get just one life and then we die
and that's the end.
All we can hope for is to get 60 or 80
or 100 years of it to do what we love,
to spend it with family and friends to
create,
to learn to do whatever we feel is
donate and give those with cystic
fibrosis the chance of 100 years.
It's why raising money is better than
raising understand and it's what they
all did
and it's what he did,
which I guess makes me the pussy.
No,
you could find information about where
to donate the dude
blog 13.